first on cbs this morning oprah winfrey
is challenging all of us to be
well to examine and actually re-examine
how the trauma
that all of us experience in one way or
another as children
can shape our world view today as adults
it's part of a new book that she
co-wrote with psychiatrist dr
bruce perry and oprah urges people to
flip the question
what's wrong with you to instead ask
what
happened to you i recently had a chance
to speak with both of them
about how these old traumas affect us
and more importantly what we can do now
to fix ourselves take a look uh so
ever since i dipped into
what happened to you the book we're here
to discuss i've been looking at
everybody on the street as a former
newborn in your phrase oprah yes it
really
that really gets to what the title
represents a reframing
of how we look at one another it's
subtle
but it's very profound oprah uh it's
subtle
but profound and powerful and
what you're experiencing tony is what i
experienced
a couple of years ago doing a piece for
60 minutes
dr bruce perry and i were talking about
a childhood trauma and in that 60
minutes interview he said the most
important question
is not what's wrong with you which is
what most people who are taking care of
children
who have had you know behavioral issues
asked what's wrong with this kid but the
most important question is
what happened to this child and
something went
whoa inside me and i i
got it in a way that i hadn't really
understood in all the years i've been
talking about trauma
trauma is a big word dr perry but
a large portion of the population
if you reflect on it has experienced
something in their life
that could be defined under that big
word trauma could you talk a little bit
about
how broad the population is that's
affected by these issues
one of the things that we're learning
more and more about
is that the stress response systems we
have in our body
will be altered and that pattern can be
something that comes from a big
event like witnessing a school shooting
or a natural disaster
or it can come from accumulated small
unpredictable uncontrollable stressors
like what will happen with a child who
is
living in an environment where they're a
in the out
group they're not the right skin color
they don't have the right
gender identity and when we look at the
number of people who have that it's well
over 40 percent of the population has
some
significant developmental adversity
that puts them at risk each of us
creates a a unique
view shaped by our life's experiences
and
most of that comes that world view as
you now read the book understand that
world view is shaped
when you are a child so most people
think tony i think
that if you're if you're in a bad
relationship
and your children are hearing things and
it's destructive
uh and dysfunctional that the children
will get over it and be resilient when
in fact you are doing the most damage
the younger your children are and those
first two
months are the most critical that's when
the messages are coming through the very
same part of the brain that's learning
language is also learning lessons
in trauma not the right lessons but the
good news and i can't
let either one of you go before we touch
on the hopeful side of this which is
once you understand the script that led
to you today
what happened to you you can rewrite
that script and it and it doesn't mean
years although it can take the work of a
lifetime it can be done
with small interventions well one of the
things i asked in the 60 minutes
interview
why aren't i stone crazy considered
how i was raised why don't i have more
problems
and one of the things you said to me
bruce is that your relationships your
relationships with teachers your
relationships
with people who cared about you eat
other than your family members so it
just means
having somebody who sees you fully sees
and recognizes you and you can connect
to that
changes the way you view yourself and
view the world and that's why what
happened to you
is so important to all of us in other
words it's love dr perry but that love
can come
in in small doses it can be a few
focused minutes your phone is put down
you're paying attention it can be an
hour long lunch with a friend it can be
a phone call a text message
absolutely and and all of those things
are examples of
the kind of therapeutic experience that
can be provided by people who are not
therapists and so healing really comes
from these
moments these moments where people are
present
attentive attuned and truly truly see
you as oprah says
well the book is 300 pages that has
grown out of
30 years of conversation and work
between the two of you
a lifetime of experience as people and
as professionals
and i hope people pick it up thanks tony
yeah you know what i thought was
interesting about the book is how trauma
affects you at eight at such a young age
like a two-month age
two-month-old because i always remember
that that saying everything i ever
know learned i learned in kindergarten
or you're fully formed by the time
you're six
yeah that's just not true one is not
true one of the things i thought was
powerful about this book is it obviously
helps with people dealing with their own
trauma but also helps with forgiveness
because we all have someone in our
family who were like geez that person is
tough
and if you stop asking what's wrong with
that person and you start asking the
question of what happened to them
to understand is the first step toward
forgiveness well the point is some of
these traumas
as he as he pointed out can be quite
small they're not necessarily
think of a trauma as you know a car
crash or something it doesn't have to be
that big and so much of what we do later
in life
it's actually a reaction to what we felt
in those early moments it's amazing the
stuff that you carry
within yourself yeah and human
connection as we all know so important